good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday it's a
beautiful day in New York a little
sensor in fresco day hey Claude how you
doing I'm good I have not opened my
blinds yet so I wasn't aware that it's a
beautiful day but thank you so much
meteorologist Jackie for letting me know
no this has really become like a weather
show since there only thing to talk
about other than coronavirus is the
weather and it's a beautiful day um I
believe it's about probably 65 degrees
outside like the perfect day all you
need is a light jacket
it's like she's Espeon or something I
know I think maybe it's like the perfect
day to go to the grocery store for me
because I'm running out of essentials I
absolutely hate going to the grocery
story so funny like what my least
favorite household chores were before
quarantine and now what they are after
like before quarantine I could not be
bothered she changed my duvet cover like
that was the one thing in my house I
wouldn't do and laundry now you know
what laundry and duvet doesn't sound so
bad when I'm like cooking for a million
meals a day running to the grocery store
like some Italian mother like that [ __ ]
sucks yeah I'm like getting to the point
like last night I ate a frozen pizza
burned my mouth I also bangs my hand so
terribly last night I was putting on a
sweatshirt in my closet I banged it on
the edge of my shelf because apparently
I don't know how to get dressed anymore
oh my god so it's like black and blue
and then there's like a literal hole of
skin that that came off like it was like
blood like it it was the saddest looking
wound I've ever seen I would [ __ ]
thought I might have broken my hand but
then the pain started to subside I
couldn't even take Advil MMMs said oh my
and now and then was like I don't [ __ ]
with a sedum OPN and now I haven't
winded like my nails here is dangerous
game I love your nails I did my nails
yesterday I'm getting so good at doing
my nails like I'm so excited for a post
q life when I have an important dinner
party yet no time to get to the manicure
place and I'm just doing it myself and
I'll just be the girl with no chipped
nails ever girl with no chips no I too
have been doing my nails kind of
religiously like it's actually insane
like the the designs that I'm just
coming up with like it's really coming
to me in the middle of the night
actually low-key like I have been up all
night I know I talk about this and
everyone is sick of me talking about it
today I actually woke up like an hour
and a half before the show to hopefully
like reset my clock because I just can't
my least favorite thing in the world is
being up at night alone Ben's asleep
can't play videos on my phone left alone
with my thoughts Lee's favorite thing
but it's been like this weirdly creative
process for me like I have been writing
so many jokes in my sleep like I wake up
I'm like sighing myself falling asleep I
think of a hilarious joke
I'll read over it oh like RuPaul is
really influencing a lot of my comedy I
can feel it already and it's just gonna
be a great tour when all this is over
tickets available girl no job com that
is so exciting yeah I woke up early yes
to reset my clock but also just to keep
free watching more RuPaul I watched a
whole other season yesterday and now I'm
halfway through another one I'm like I
am becoming a historian and now like my
friends especially TBG he loves drag
race and he is like drag me to a bunch
of drag shows with people from the show
but like I didn't really know it and
like I just like was not really into it
and now that I'm into it he's like so
excited like we are going to take the
drag world by storm after this like I'm
hitting a drag show every night post
quarantine that's so exciting that you
have something to look forward to like
that
a new home yeah I guess maybe I'll go
visit waco after the quarantine to see
the hallowed halls actually a lot of
people are watching waco now I don't
know what it's trending I mean I guess
maybe it just came to Netflix and that's
why it's like number 5 on Netflix but
also then like the toast was talking
about it so maybe that influenced it a
little bit but now a lot of the toasters
are watching it so I'm gonna do like an
in-depth of recap later this week when
enough people have watched it because
still I don't want to spoil the ending
because if you've never heard the story
the ending is worse than anything you
could have imagined while watching it
yes but you know we all have something
to look forward to because today we have
Francesca farrago from too hot to handle
on the toast if you're listening as a
podcast
it'll just be at the end of this podcast
episode if you watch this on YouTube the
video will be uploaded separately it was
a fabulous episode she looked so
snatched just like sitting in Vancouver
she's so standing she was just like an
open book she's Jessica Simpson herself
like there's no question that she
wouldn't answer and there's like she had
like she's just an open book I and she's
so awesome I'm so glad that we got to
talk to her and I just love that like
for us the only people that we've had on
our show during the quarantine are dr.
deborah birx and francesca farrago
because we are women who support
incredible women game-changing women
know true and when I sat down at dinner
last night to like tell Ben cuz then
watched you out to handle I was like
honestly she gave us so much tea like I
was telling Ben I'm like I feel like
this was like a groundbreaking interview
we didn't even prod her for it like she
was just forthcoming with information
so Ariana Grande stuff was crazy the
Justin Bieber stuff oh yeah and then
also at the Shradha and Rhonda stuff
right so um that will be available like
as you're watching this that is
available somewhere so make sure to
check it out and watch you
hard-to-handle if you having had it's
like just a treat in the queue you know
it's just one day in the queue but you
know one day at a time one time in the
queue like one day is so long and I know
it sounds so sad but like before bed Ben
was really falling asleep like and I was
begging him to stay awake with me and
I'm like I just and it sounded so like
dark but I was like I just don't want to
be awake and it wasn't like that but
like I just debt like I just want to
like not be so like isolated with my
thoughts like does anyone else have like
really annoying thoughts at night like I
think of all the like embarrassing
things I've ever done in my life like in
my dorm of course I think of everything
embarrassing I've ever done in my life
I'm like why am i who I am like I'm so
embarrassing a hundred percent
and it's like things that I haven't
thought about in years just suddenly
become unearthed simply because I cannot
sleep a hundred percent it's like
repressed memory like and it's all it
just comes back to you in a state of
like of cue oh but you know what I did
find it was being like so shady boots on
my fence till last night I wanted to
watch tic TOCs but Ben was asleep and I
found like a new Instagram account that
does like blogger tea and I'm obsessed
I'll send it to you I'm not gonna like
put on last because I don't know this
really is a great time for a blogger tea
I know it's just like so piping oh well
cool
I dabbled in and out of poverty but just
I feel like sometimes I don't know the
people that they're talking about you
know and then all the bloggers are the
same to me and I'm like what makes this
blog or different like why now why'd
this blogger so ya know bloggers are
very similar but to me the ones that
really stand out are the ones that
listen to the toast Kathleen Barnes
champagne and Chanel they stand out
because they have fabulous taste in
podcasts oh I agree those aren't the
ones I'm talking about me neither I
don't even I don't even know which ones
to talk about if I know your handle I'm
not talking about you you know you know
there's like a brand of bloggers who
have become like people become obsessed
with their lives because they look live
in fancy houses but like they literally
all at the same they all look the same
I'll wear the same stuff the Nordstrom
spring sale like it's that photo get it
out with all the girls in fall yeah
those are the girls I'm talking about I
don't know one of their names but that's
what I'm talking about
same okay cool well we have a good show
for you today like the celebs are coming
out you know not coming out of the queue
obviously because we are all sheltering
in place but they're making moves in the
queue and they're making babies and
we're so grateful for that so I think
it's time I think it is for the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I think I'm gonna
have some morning toast today actually I
just got some fresh avocados so I think
it's time for an avocado toast it's been
a while I actually don't have a toaster
I thought you have a toaster oven I do
it's a toaster yeah you could make toast
in there I don't have a toaster I have a
toaster oven oh yeah toaster ovens a
fabulous appliance yeah there's some
things where it's a little annoying and
actually no anything that you can make
in a toaster you can make it into a sir
oven but not anything that you could
make in a toaster oven
could you make in a toaster a lot of
things you can though from the oven
no no but you you can make more in a
toaster oven than Canon toaster so
you're better off so you're better I
know and almost anything you can make in
an oven you can make in a toaster oven
like I was baking cookies in our toaster
oven sweet I'm comparing a toaster oven
to a toaster oh it's so much better you
can't make [ __ ] in a toaster no you
literally can only make bread you can't
even make a bagel because this the the
little slice okay for bread you're like
shoving a bagel it's like me trying it
into my Spanx and it's honestly toasters
no offense are nothing of the sort
there's nothing of the sort or like you
could have a bagel if you want it to be
like a thin bagel with no juice and meat
but if you want like a delicious juicy
New York bagel like it's not gonna work
in that toaster that's what they call a
flagel and honestly flagels flat nails
aren't the sort flagels are good like
I'm talking about a bagel from the
supermarket that thinks it's tomato
walks around like like it's a bagel and
it's nothing of the sort
it's like a round bread ya know it's
like that company that makes English
muffins like also makes bagels in like a
saran wrap too but there's like six
bagels like those are not bagels I
bought one of those saran wrap tubes and
bagels I don't know what company it was
I bought it at the beginning of the
queue and I've been keeping it in my
fridge and I've been treating myself to
like a bagel on the weekend in my
toaster oven so good
the it's like a big juicy bagel in a
fleet Pataki you literally live like one
block away from one of the most big
amazing bagel stores that I have
actually been ordering bagels from that
store and freezing them
I'm sheltering in place what can I say
they're on uber eats I don't know I
don't I don't order it we read some
listen unless I really feel like I have
to and I need some like protein that I
can't get at home
I've ordered ubereats like probably
three or four times during quarantine
it's a lovely you know way to shake it
up it's a treat for me I probably do it
like order in maybe once a week it just
it depends on what I'm in the mood for
and if I don't have the cooking bug if I
have ingredients like it's just yeah
it's touch and go you know I tell you
that I was watching an episode of
RuPaul's Drag Race yesterday and
basically how the show works is like if
you're on the bottom two you have to
lip-sync for your life where it's like
whoever gives like a better lip singing
performance wins and they always pick
like iconic gay songs like you like you
could guess you know and they chose
shake it up by Selena Gomez the shake it
off Chicago theme song but it is strange
no that's amazing yeah it's honestly a
gay iconic show I mean song soft shaking
it up shake it up it's actually not a
great song but I like the the thought it
worked in the moment like the Queen's
were just like living and they you know
what it's really impressive like we know
the words tell like a million songs but
they really know every single word to
every old contemporary like they have to
know every single lyric it's crazy that
is crazy
damn okay are you ready it wasn't time
before it really wasn't I guess like I
don't know what I saying but now it is
time for the past I started that you
need to know before we commit to get
bite up your morning toast and I'm gonna
be happy kind of Kyoto soon and do you
know that toaster oven is actually
better than a toaster first up first up
Christine Kevin okay we I don't know if
we got it like so wrong yesterday or I'm
just so confused now okay
in the Kristin Cavallari Jay Cutler saga
Kristin Cavallari has cited quote
inappropriate marital conduct in her
divorce from Jay Cutler so the divorce
filings are coming out for Kristin and
Jay and it it does not look good at all
okay in divorce documents obtained by
people one day after the couple
announced their split Caribou Larry
alleges both quote irreconcilable
differences an inappropriate marital
conduct as grounds for the breakup in
her filing she claims that Cult Cutler
is quote guilty of such inappropriate
behavior inappropriate marital conduct
as renders further cohabitation unsafe
and improper she also states that any
misconduct alleged or implied against
her in Cutler's divorce petition was in
response to and/or as a result of
misconduct on his behalf though Cutler
does not seem to allege misconduct
against her while many people people are
familiar with irreconcilable differences
these huge words I'm just like people
are familiar with irreconcilable
differences as grounds for divorce
marital misconduct is a less familiar
term more commonly used in divorce
filings in fault states in the u.s.
those that require parties to prove
fault as a reason for their divorce
Tennessee where Cavallari and color Wed
and currently reside is a fault state so
that term is like normal
Tennessee Salish even left field saying
that his behavior has been um
misconducted you know yeah I mean I just
think like we were slightly naive in
thinking like this was just gonna be
perfect there's a lot of money at stake
and it's been a what like there it
wasn't just like a floozy marriage it
was a 10-year marriage and they have
kids like it's gonna be a little messy
I don't know so at first I read like
what TMZ said and they're saying some
crazy [ __ ] in there like gonna fight
over custody and he cited the date at
like they have two different dates of
when they cited its getting divorced
like hers was literally the day they got
back from the Bahamas making you think
that something happened the bomb is in
his was a few days later making you
think like something happened in the
queue um so at first I was like oh my
god this is so messy we're so naive like
I literally believe everything that I
read I mean I love a TV and I read it on
TV and like I'm just I don't know
anything of the sort and I was like sad
for them and for me for believing at all
but then I was reading in the toasters
group and there was a Tennessee lawyer
toaster who was writing and saying that
pretty much what this People magazine
article is saying that like that
statement of marital misconduct is kind
of just like a blanket term and it
doesn't necessarily mean anything and
everything that they've said in their
court filings are kind of like boxes
that you they're not terms they came up
with their own they're like just this
blanket things that you check these are
like boilerplate divorce filings in
Tennessee so it might be amicable no I
believe that I just I don't think I I
think one in 50 divorces is like
applicable dream we love each other
we're still friends like we co-parent
that's just like not a reality
especially in Hollywood and especially
when there's so much money involved like
we looked up Jay Cutler's salary being a
hundred and fifty million dollars like
as much as I would like to think that
it's you know really all perfect and
they're just doing everything for the
kids I just have a feeling this will be
like a messy one and it won't just be
you know a dividing of the things yeah I
I agree with that it's gonna be messier
than we then we thought yesterday I just
for some reason think that they're good
friends and they were never it's not
like they just fell out of love
yesterday like I think they've been out
of love for a long time but it didn't
bother them now of course you know
everyone's like coming out of the
woodwork with all there are rumors and
allegations and story
and it's like Jay's been doing whatever
he wants for years and Kristen hasn't
cared um if that's true though it still
begs the question like why now why this
marital misconduct yeah I mean as much
as you and I like love to believe that
certain people in pro sports like are
good and righteous more often than not
it is a toxic environment even some of
our favorites you know like there is
temptation and I just think that um you
you know you go into a marriage with a
pro athlete with that understanding but
I think where it draws the line and this
is just totally speculation it's like
when this person starts stepping out on
you and like embarrassing you and not
being quiet about it anymore like people
now coming to the woodwork hug I saw Jay
with this person and I was at a concert
and he was there like if you're gonna
start embarrassing your wife I feel like
that's when your wife becomes a lot less
understanding about the lifestyle you
lead maybe I don't know that I think
that that makes sense in general but
like it's not like you know we got
photos of him with another woman
and now she has to like take a stand I
know but I wonder what part of it wasn't
still working the good news is that she
does have a reality show and so will
maybe understand some of this one day
because she is sort of open with her
fans not at once but eventually maybe
we'll get to know it all so this lawyer
that People magazine has they said there
are strategic decisions you make with
all of the divorce filings we have 15
different grounds for divorce in
Tennessee irreconcilable differences is
certainly the least aversive and the
more amicable one marital misconduct is
the next Lisa Burson and they can kick
up from there so it's like it sounds
worse than it is yeah and people are
like little running with the misconduct
word like because people just assume
that means cheating um but I get that
it's like a legal jargon moment yes it
is um but I also don't think it's as
sweet as their Instagram captions made
it seem except that they're both posting
the exact same Instagram caption they're
obviously like communicating whether
it's through PR person but clearly
they're on the same page right now
that's true actually does say a lot that
they posted like the same statement
because we've seen with like Jim Edmonds
and Megan King like social media can
play a very toxic role in a divorce and
you can really tell if the people are
like working together or not
Megan cannons and [ __ ] let's see Jim Jim
we're not but that's true it's a good
sign it's a sign of life right so
overall like it's not as great as we
thought dr. Theodor for Chapman is gonna
have to weigh him later
um it's not as good as we thought but
like it might not be as bad as it seems
but it's not good we'll see we will just
see we will see okay next story some
happy celeb news Lea Michele is pregnant
expecting her first bed bet with husband
sandy rice Lea Michele and husband's
Annie Bryce have something to be khlifa
about the 33 year old actress is
expecting her first child with the 37
year old entrepreneur pink six has
confirmed a source told people who first
reported the news that quote they've
always wanted to be parents this is just
so sweet a quarantine Biba so sweet like
there is such a special place in my
heart for Lea Michele 1 because she's
sang her way into my heart you know 10
years ago on the set of Glee but also
she's just like the famous person like
that I would be you know she's so
talented and she's such a nice girl like
when she was on our show I just I fell
in love with her even more I'm so happy
for I think she's gonna be a great mom
now there's a lot of speculation within
the weekly community and I think that I
am you know spokesperson for that
community as to whether or not the
baby's name will pay homage to Finn
Hudson okay Cory Monteith I think it's
wildly inappropriate but people think
that it's a possibility
I think it's wildly inappropriate like
never even crossed my mind never crossed
my mind she does at the tattoo of him
but I mean tattoos are symbolic and
there's a real baby coming into the
world I don't think she's gonna do it I
think no I don't think I don't think
either but you know it'll be interesting
to see I wonder how far along she is
like she definitely did get pregnant in
quarantine but it's a look at a few
months in a few months we'll know who
did yeah or when she gives birth we'll
be able to do some you know retroactive
math and see if the baby was conceived
during quarantine but I'm there
like in a few months the endowment last
month isn't really announcing it this
month been a few months like
announcements of pregnancies whatever
celeb pregnancies are announcing that
will probably mean that they got
pregnant in the queue are you thinking
of anyone in particular yes I am because
I saw it in the toasters but I hate when
people speculate on pregnancy based on
absolutely nothing and just like what
they want for a couple so I'm keeping my
mouth shut but like the odds are that
there's gonna be at least one cube
debbye yeah can we talk about um sophie
turner for a minute because it was
reported widely confirmed that she was
pregnant we reported it too because
literally like everyone reported it and
they just haven't really mentioned it so
it's very possible that she's just
keeping it private which is totally
respectable but I just feel like there
hasn't even been like a nod towards it
yeah um it's it's interesting strategy I
think for sure that she is and that's
why she's like she's not talking about
it but maybe she just like wanted maybe
she had a plan like to announce whenever
whatever time she wanted to and she's
stickin to that plan you know yeah it's
also very possible that she's just not
pregnant yeah but then like she would I
feel like we would be seeing her
drinking and stuff in quarantine because
I got sue and Julie you know I feel like
she would have addressed it like it was
such a nation-wide it was reported as
fact like not even just speculation or a
rumor yeah so I the type of person who
would have said something about it yeah
but they've been like going live a lot
like cooking you know if I I think if
they weren't pregnant like they would be
drinking and stuff yeah even though I'm
like so getting over drinking in the
court in the queue like you used to get
drunk just like past the time now I get
drunk and the board I'm like really
really sets in and I get like depressed
yeah it's it's a it's a fine line maybe
usually switch up the alcohol that you
are drinking so you'll have a different
kind of drunk experience and you'll feel
a new sensation that's interesting I
could maybe take a break from white
Claus like if you just drank a whiskey
who knows what would happen that's
exciting yeah maybe me like try crack
no I don't think that's the vibe for the
queue maybe not
we'll say maybe like a psychedelic
though and then all of a sudden like you
have all the stuff going on in your
apartment yeah but you know I feel like
an apartment is a very confined space to
be doing psychedelics like I think you
need square footage to like rain free I
was watching a TV show oh younger when
they went on that LSD retreat you know
like they needed or they needed space
and I just feel like my apartment
doesn't offer me the spatial needs that
LSD requires I understand that ok so
you'll have to maybe table that idea for
now ok ready for our next story yep
Facebook is going to stream a 20/20
graduation event with Oprah Miley Cyrus
and more Facebook will celebrate
America's graduating seniors with a
live-streaming event next month that
will include a commencement address by
Oprah Winfrey and a lineup of other
celebs in addition to Oprah's keynote
the may 15th event will feature Miley
Cyrus performing her perseverance themed
hit the climb Wow is that she just [ __ ]
all over this story and things changed
celebrities on tap to address the class
of 2020 in the live stream include
Jennifer Garner lil nas Aquafina and
Olympic champion gymnast Simone biles
basic expects to announce additional
guests later thoughts I
I mean I don't know who this is really
for because when I think of living yours
no I get that like college or high
school I think it's just seniors across
the world but probably college cuz like
that's yeah I just don't think like in
high schools high school graduations
don't get a keynote from Oprah so oh
yeah okay I know I just I'm not a
graduating senior but I have a tick tock
and I feel like that gives me a real
insight like a microscope a lens into
what the class of 2020 are feeling like
I just feel like this is not what they
want like they don't really unless it
like when you get a keynote speech at
your graduation like it's cool because
you're there you don't need to like if
Oprah had was coming to one of these
kids graduations like it would be a big
deal but like they could watch a video
of Oprah on the internet on YouTube like
they don't need a special event to me
this is just like I don't know who this
is for like to me it's more for like
news outlets to write it up and I think
maybe someone you watch the climb these
kids they don't [ __ ] want this they
want to get drunk like they don't want a
[ __ ] live stream here's the thing
though like I am like the client like
without it out in this world I had to
climb the songs number one fan there's
no question I mind no one could possibly
love it more than me and I won't be
watching this also I think what takes
away from this is that really anyone can
watch this you don't have to be a senior
graduating it's just like a marketing
ploy but they should make it so that
like you have to be a little prove that
you're a senior like non seniors can't
watch yeah like sign up with your you
know NYU ID number this is just so this
is really not it
like about a lot of the things that have
been put together for quote-unquote our
benefit um this is just maybe at the top
of the list of things we didn't need so
thank you but no thank you
yeah but you know if you're a graduating
senior and like you're into this let us
know maybe we're just yeah maybe we're
not like understanding what it's like to
not get a commencement yeah I mean you
know I actually did not go to my
commencement so I do kind of relate
because it was boring and they didn't
even get anyone famous so like I was I'm
out of here but I would agree I would
like to hear for some from some
graduating seniors is this what you want
does this make you feel better are you
gonna watch if I were graduating senior
what I would want is I would want my
camp
to host a graduation in a year from now
like for us that way we get to come back
in a year it's like a homecoming sash
like reunion but it's only one year
later and like everyone's still hyped on
college I think that would be so fun and
that would totally make up for not
getting to graduate like this year I
think that sounds fabulous and a really
good fun and fresh idea yeah and then
they could also even if they want to
like lump me in with 2021 like it was
like to separate like put us in the
morning them in the afternoon whatever
you got to do but you can make us all
like one weekend so you're not spending
like all this additional money on like
chairs and stuff um and I think it could
be pop in something about this event
just like seems so sad to me I think
it's the fact that it's so broad like if
you're graduating like there's no school
there's no association like doesn't make
you feel like part of a group it
honestly probably makes you feel so like
lonely you know here's I just found the
saddest excerpt that I think is really
gonna touch on what's so sad the social
giant Facebook is also enabling grads to
host their own digital ceremonies and
parties via the Facebook app with
special features including a virtual
graduation hub custom filters and video
chats through its new messenger rooms
feature Wow
some filters I just like what's wrong
with FaceTime no nothing and like
Facebook is just always doing the most
when nobody asked them to know legit
nobody asked for this that's so lame and
honestly like iris yeah if you're like I
just think like whenever Miley in this
day and age is like attaching her names
and stuff like it's automatically a bad
sign like and you know I think to
present a hundred percent
she has just like really shown she has
like no space like she's not a bar yes
she'll just do anything like bright mind
like I just think when I heard her name
was attached I was like but then Oprah
it's like this elegant like beacon of
light and hope for so many people and
she's the goals keynote speaker for any
graduation like that is as good as it
gets we're gettin Oprah for our
graduation so it's like when Oprah's
associated to something I automatically
think it's like fabulous but then Miley
Cyrus like really brings down and I
don't like just like Miley I just think
like as an entertainer and as a brand
like whoever's running her brand is
doing a horrible job like she when I
think of her I just don't think of
anything I don't think of pop star I
don't think of Instagram like I don't
think of anything like I just think of
person who's always showing up places
when like nobody wanted her there yeah
well at least whoever's like running the
show was like okay Miley you're gonna
come with her we want you to or not
please just sing the climb that is the
only redeeming thing she could do yeah
like on SNL what the [ __ ] was she
singing and by the fire like I thought
she was literally gonna engulfed in
flames
oh well you know what that's a great
segue into our next story I didn't see
my Dennis and I actually started to
watch the episode um but I was painfully
bored but dr. pouchy is praising Brad
Pitt's quote classy impersonation of him
on SNL so um
Brad Pitt impersonated dr. pouchy on us
and now everyone was like so excited
about it
dr. fout she said I think he did great
I'm a great fan of Brad Pitt and that's
the reason why when people ask me who I
would like to play me
I mentioned Brad Pitt's cuz people had
asked him who who should play him on SNL
and he had said Brad Pitt he's one of my
favorite actors I think he'd
a great job um like I like the idea
behind this is so cute and I love Brad
Pitt like what could be like what can I
say um except I'll all say is I couldn't
watch it I mean of course doctor foul
she loves Brad Pitt playing him that's
like me dang I want [ __ ] Megan Fox
like of course no offense doctor foul
she's like a little weenie like you know
like in the real world like he looks
nothing like Brad Pitt of course he's
praising this like that's like the goal
like that what how flattering how
complimentary of SNL honestly like real
comedy would have leaned into the fact
that he weighs like 90 pounds like it's
great and I'm happy for him and doctor
foul she deserves the world cuz he's you
know doing good stuff but like come on
of course he loves it ya know it also it
just like didn't I didn't it wasn't very
good but you know to me it's um cuz I
don't have a normal you know perception
of the world it's a mismatch yeah also
like when Brad was doing like whatever
mannerisms about she like I wasn't
getting pouchy vibes you know and you
should SNL like you like Larry David
Bernie Sanders like I can't separate the
two anymore even like everyone that Kate
McKinnon does I can't separate like
every time I see like anyone that she
appears nice I'm like oh it's Kate
McKinnon totally like you have an
automatic association with the people
like they really become Woody Harrelson
like becomes Joe Biden I totally agree
if it weren't for the glasses I would
have no idea what he was talking about
yes no I agree but I guess it was a cute
idea to cute people doing something not
cute yeah no but this is a news story
it's like he loved it of course he loved
it it's Brad Pitt does it honestly
doctor fact she's gonna have an inflated
sense of self after this because he's
gonna think he actually resembles Brad
Pitt when sorry spoiler alert
you know yeah I'm happy for him to like
that if that's you know if that's the
gift of doing you know important work
for our country you get to be played by
Brad Pitt go for it you know I would
have cast something something
more long lines are like a Martin Short
who's that guy Martin Short he was on
comedians and cars
he's like a comedy duo with Steve Martin
he's like really sure and like small he
looks honestly very similar body type to
that's great that's great dr. Pat
annoyed I feel like there's a lot of
people that that could have nailed the
role honestly in a lot of ways I think
Pete Davidson could have done it they
both have like that skinny vibe yeah I
see it yeah okay are you ready for a
fitting final story it's like it's
actually I'm gonna say it's some good
news it is good news I don't know why
that's like a hot take Felicity Huffman
is so proud after her daughter gets into
a top university on her own SAT scores
following the scandal Sophia may see the
daughter khalessi happenin and William H
Macy has been accepted into Carnegie
Mellon University and will be attending
the school's prestigious theater program
this fall the 19 year old shared the
news on Instagram by updating her bio to
read CMU drama 24 Sophia's younger
sister Georgia will also be heading to
the East Coast come fall as a freshman
at Vassar College felicity is so proud
and grateful that sophia has kept her
chin up over the last year it was a
painful challenging time and she pulled
through it with strength and grace so
explain to me the timeline because her
kids are just now going to college but
she paid $15,000 yes so maybe I don't
know maybe act when everything was going
down like the girls just didn't wind up
going to whatever school they were gonna
go to and then they took the test again
or the one daughter took the test again
and then went where her grades took her
which is a great school yeah I mean
honestly I don't know how any of these
kids get into college on their own
accord like now you know yeah yeah I
don't know somebody's confusing no no no
I feel like they're really you know
learning from their mistakes
no of course but it's like Carnegie
Mellon isn't a bad school so it's like
how did they get in well maybe she's
like not maybe she's smart but no of
course which is a permanent yeah no no
of course I'm not denying maybe she had
the grades but like with that kind of
like [ __ ] stain on your permanent record
like I just find it shocking that she
would get into college when the [ __ ]
stain is literally College assented yeah
but it wouldn't be it's not on her what
record is it on like it's not that she's
not a click opinion yeah but maybe she I
don't know maybe there are some people
in the admissions department who gives
second chances or maybe some of these
colleges needed a little press I don't
think it was a pressing and like the
fact that the only confirmation is in
her Instagram bio it's like who even
found this that is an important question
yeah so they're gonna go school together
cute no the other ones going to pass her
but they'll both be on the East Coast
okay I think it said happy ending she
served her time she did her crime she
served her time the kids took the test
again they're going to school they're
still going to college they weren't like
you know they could have been like oh
[ __ ] this totally no it's not the end
I'm a firm believer in second chances I
think that this is great I was just a
little shocked that they could still get
into college I mean you never know
anything's possible but it I agree it is
like it is a little interesting like
that's crazy but cool maybe she's just
an actress do you think the corona virus
pandemic will have any bearing on Lori
Loughlin
trial or anything I feel like it could I
do I feel like it's shaking up Chicago
the entire like courts and prison system
you know people are getting out people
are coming in it's crazy I when I
couldn't sleep I actually went on empty
for the first time in a while and one of
the blinds was that um she's negotiating
a plea deal using the pandemic to kind
of urge for like a strict to stay at
home home arrest oh that would be I mean
I feel like and I feel like I had been
saying this that I felt like she was
gonna find some sort of
legal loophole and that she wasn't gonna
wind up going to jail because it's like
Kevin Spacey isn't in jail you know and
honestly I'm Lori Loughlin and that's
why I think I have the most respect for
Felicity Huffman because she didn't try
and find a loophole like she fully
admitted her her uh the amount that she
paid was much less so her sentencing it
was much less so it was probably easier
for her to like plead guilty um but I
just have respect for someone who takes
accountability for their actions like
she homegirl went to jail for two weeks
yeah and the whole thing is behind her
and so a fresh start for her daughter's
that's why I'm really here for this
story yeah I mean you know I'm so
concerned about the William H Macy of it
all like I felt like they were very
publicly disassociated from one another
during her trial yeah I just feel like
you can't trust what you see you know
after watching all these shows and like
even watching waco like the [ __ ] that
was in the press that was such lies wait
I don't know how we believe anything
that I mean we just have to are the rise
we would just be like you know you got
it just trust no but I don't I don't
believe anything that I read like I
don't believe any tweets I don't believe
anything like unless I see with my own
two eyes I don't believe it yes so I
think when it comes to William H mace
and Felicity Huffman like I'm not
worried about them if they were getting
a divorce they would be divorced they're
still together I think they lived if
they didn't live together even now like
they're [ __ ] together they just like
are doing their own thing totally um
very well said Jackie thanks um speaking
of Waco everybody should watch like the
more that people are watching and the
more like a snitch just watchin it's
just such it's just the show is so well
done and I just love a true story you
know cuz it's not like I'm wasting my
emotions on some fiction that's why I
love reality TV um and I think it's such
an important story that a lot of people
including myself did not know and if
you're looking for something to watch
stay tuned for our interview with
Francesca farrago she spills so much tea
like everything she says
t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t so much stuff about
celebrities that are not watching the
show stuff we didn't see on camera it's
a really fabulous interview and
she's such a nice girl so I think you
guys are gonna enjoy it podcast
listeners it is coming right up after
this youtube listeners it is available
on our channel um we love you guys we
hope you have a great day
shred you the sign off now yeah I think
that's all she wrote thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up if you're watching us we're
also available as podcasts anywhere
podcasts can be found set Spotify iTunes
stitcher public radio I our radio cast
box all the places so ever you listen to
podcast find us the morning tell us to
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys we will see you tomorrow
bye